[Music]
well a very good morning to you it is
the dawn of a very different day for
people in england with a significant
easing of lockdown restrictions
midnight drinkers took full advantage of
their first pint
outside a pub in more than three months
as some businesses got the green light
to reopen but a warning from the prime
minister for people to behave
responsibly
so let's take a look at what rules
change from
today and pubs restaurants
hospitality venues will be open able to
reopen for
outdoor service with no curfew and no
requirement for a substantial meal
that's if you want to drink alcohol of
course now holidays and overnight stays
in england will be allowed with the same
household
but the government has told people to
minimize domestic travel
where they can self-contained holiday
accommodation like campsites
will be able to welcome guests back
non-essential retail
hairdressers and nail salons can open
their doors as well from today
and indoor leisure facilities like gyms
and spas will be allowed to reopen
but not saunas or steam rooms
senior chowdhury reports
the first pint back
and the countdown has been a long time
coming
four three two
one ladies and gentlemen take your seats
have your first drinks please come down
they've been waiting for this since
before christmas
this bar in bexley heath wasted no time
opening its doors
but people can't go inside just 18
people here tonight
and they all have to sit outdoors and
it's safe to say that most people are
used to the social
distancing but today comes with a fresh
plea from the prime minister
for people to behave responsibly oh some
people will some people won't
good bad you know some people are going
to flatten they but
we're all going to behave ourselves i'm
not having any more
sociable again isn't it that's the thing
because we've all missed it but
i know we've had two and we're still
going to be sensible we hope
because we don't want another knockdown
as long as people don't have too much i
think everyone's just
looking forward to getting back to
normal again
[Music]
today's re-openings include gyms and
swimming pools
non-essential retail and hair salons
roller coasters are back too
hands face space is still the key
message
with the new addition of fresh air
jake greaves's pub garden in bromley is
stunning
but it's the inside he misses for us to
feel like things things are truly back
to normal
is for people to be back at the bar
again and ordering drinks
it's a bit to be honest i mean we're a
pub at the end of the day and
uh table service it's it's it's nice
from a customer point of view but for
operating
as a pub it's very difficult it's not
what we're used to
at all really boris johnson has called
this a major step forward in our roadmap
to freedom
but there's still some distance to go
sadia chowdhury sky news
well fraser moored is in a gym in
birmingham for us this morning but first
let's go to becky cottrell who's in a
hairdresser's in west london i know
becky the prime minister is getting his
hair cut
well about now i can imagine all
hairdressers
are going to be pretty busy this week
yeah i'm at harry's in chelsea in london
lots of eager people coming in to get
their hair cut they've been open since
6 a.m this morning trying to fit
customers in they've got a waiting list
of 3 000 people so they're opening for
longer hours during the day
and going seven days a week to get them
all in i spoke to one customer today who
said that this really meant a lot to her
because she's had to wear her hair in a
ponytail
for the past few months so finally gets
to have a haircut
it's a big day and i'm joined by tony
hendry who is the salon manager and
senior stylist here
tony tell me about demand how many
people are trying to get their hair cut
hi becky well it's been absolutely
outrageous to be honest with you we've
had a
serious waiting list we've still got
people on the waiting list so it's taken
us over
three to four weeks to get the bookings
in um
and we just sort of cautiously going
forward and
trying to do the right thing with all
the covert restrictions and everything
so it's
yeah i think we're sitting back in our
chair and just taking it as it comes and
trying to do the right thing
and just tell me quickly how tough has
it been for you as a business this past
year well as a business for the whole
year it's been
um very challenging i have to say lots
of different changes that we've had to
imply
um the thing is most of the time what
we've had to do
is um um
it's been tough hasn't it it's been
really tough and you have 150 members of
staff
they've been on furlough but thankfully
the furlough scheme has been supporting
them
and hopefully this will be the last time
that this salon and many of the salons
across the country have to close
okay becky thank you well let's head to
birmingham then
and uh you don't look dressed for a gym
fraser after
you know you're not thinking of getting
stuck in yourself this morning
well i was worried i might put people
off if they saw just how buff i was they
might
realize that their aspirations would be
too high if they're trying to match my
physical manliness but there's about 400
members here at the temple gym in
birmingham a couple of dozen of them
have been through the doors
already it opens at six o'clock this
morning and quite a few people are
already in
they're getting back into their daily
routines and of course we know that
we've been hearing a lot about mental
health during the pandemic and the
lockdown restrictions and so on and
and physical health is of course one way
to achieve
good mental health as well can have a
chat with one of our gym goers now i'm
so sorry afton to disturb you in the
middle of your circuit at the moment so
just tell us why were you so keen to get
back through the door you were the first
one in at six o'clock this morning yeah
i've been very excited sort of like
christmas day kind of feeling
um i think it's just because it's been
such a long
year or year and a half so many of us
and
yeah i think the lock down has been
quite isolating for a lot of people
and being able to come back in the gym
and get back into lifting it's like
really important for everyone's mental
health
and being back with other people seeing
people training and
people that you normally see every day
it's kind of feeling of normality
um i think this lockdown has really
highlighted that mental health aspects
hasn't it because of course everybody
knows that
gyms are great for physical well-being
but i think during this lockdown it's
become so much more apparent to people
just how important it is for mental
well-being as well yeah definitely i
think
um so many people really rely on it as a
way of sort of venting getting out sort
of stress and
it's a breakup between sort of home and
work and it's really
something you can work to even though
it's through the physical health you
know it all comes together
um when you're in the gym so
brilliant well afton thank you very much
i'll let you get back to your circuit
now you're doing a great job this
morning certainly
putting yourself through your paces so
uh so after one of many members here
will be hoping to uh
to get back into their daily routine
great for physical well-being and of
course
great for mental health too yeah
absolutely fraser thank you
well let's get a bit more on the later
stage of the road map out of lockdown
we're joined by the former chief
scientific advisor and member of the
independent sage group
sir david king good to see you once
again sir david look
what's your view on on this new stage
out of lockdown kicking off today do you
think this is happening at the right
time
well i i have to admit that i'm one of
those who rather badly needs a haircut
so i'm looking forward to to getting my
hair cut of course a long waiting list
and all that
um i i think that from our point of view
the population itself we're all dying
to get out of lockdown and
so from that point of view it's very
clear from the point of view of the
epidemic i think
it's all a little bit more worrying and
there i have to stress
uh what is now happening for example in
chile chile is a country where
the rate of vaccination amongst the
population was the third highest in the
world
and they they were ahead of us in terms
of the number of
people who've had the vaccine and
they're suddenly now into a third wave
and their third wave they now have 7 600
cases a day
and the the total number of people in
chile now who have
covet 19 is over a million so what what
has happened in chile is very very
surprising
high percentage of people have been
vaccinated
but here's a variant of the disease
coming through the country
i mean i know we have to be very
concerned about variants but with
i mean it'd be very difficult wouldn't
it to maintain lockdown restrictions
when we're looking at
in the last sort of 24-hour period 1730
cases
seven deaths i mean it's the lowest
recorded deaths we've had since
september i mean that that that has to
be providing some some encouragement
doesn't it
no exactly and the rate of vaccination
of over 55 year olds is
over 90 it's really incredible how the
vaccination has been rolled out through
the national health service but what i
what i do want to stress is if you
look at world health organizations
advice
to all countries it is test
trace isolate and support all of those
who have the disease that's the
only way you safely emerge from the
disease
look at australia look at new zealand
you also have to
see that your incoming people
from other countries are free of the
disease so i think the biggest problem
we have
is that our fine test trace isolation
support system
has never produced that result the
government has to grab hold of it it's
spending 135 billion pounds
in the private sector companies of our
money public money
on this process and it hasn't succeeded
if we have a new
outbreak we need to separate everyone
with the disease and those have been in
contact with them
from the rest of the population and then
we can go on
with our business is there a concern as
well at the moment
over virus hot spots i mean the idea
that we are treating
england as a whole and not we don't seem
to be getting a lot of focus on virus
hot spots even though we know they exist
yes you're quite right and of course the
the
extent of the covet 19 outbreak now of
daily extent
is is much lower in the south than in
the north but as you might
predict the the cities with
relatively high density populations of
people who are
not wealthy people who are not middle
class people who are
really suffering there we have seen no
real focus from the government on on
stepping into those communities with
people from those communities
to see that we get proper isolation that
we see that we get proper lockdown
so you're quite right wherever there is
disease
we know there is a risk and let me also
add then
it is in our self-interest to get
vaccination occurring around the world
wherever it occurs in the world whatever
we do
it will arrive here so we have an
interest in
really getting this disease out of the
way in our own country and particularly
in deprived areas
but also of course overseas
we we have a massive production capacity
for vaccines
why we haven't dreamt it up here in
britain i just have
no idea we still depend on importing
from
manufacturers out in other countries
but nevertheless we need to support
strongly and i
i think the notion that the g7 put
forward by gordon brown
that the g7 ought to be supporting
international vaccination
is really top rate we must support that
and so with all that in mind and i think
a lot of people will absolutely
appreciate
your sentiment that if we don't tackle
it everywhere on the globe
we're going to end up with a problem
back here with that in mind
do you think that there should be the
focus that there is
on trying to ease holiday foreign travel
restrictions
by the summer should that be something
that we rule out till
next year at the earliest
yes i think perhaps although you you
know
we i'm in favor of having a traffic
light system for countries so
if we're talking about traveling
directly to a country with a very low
rate of the
disease and if the proper precautions
are taken that you're fully tested or
fully vaccinated
then i i think it is quite feasible to
allow people to
to travel overseas but i think it should
be on a very restrictive basis
i i think that we know that the south
african variant for example has come
into this
country there's a significant take-up of
it here
and the brazilian variant i don't
believe
we can keep it out of the country so the
the importance of the fine test trace
isolate and support system
just cannot be overestimated i do not
understand
why we talk about testing capacity which
is now enormous that's very good
without understanding the whole point of
testing
is that you can isolate those people who
test positive
and all of those who've been in contact
with them we're not going to do that
particularly in deprived communities
if we don't then also support those
people
who have to be isolated that means
financially supporting them
but also supporting them if they cannot
be isolated
in their own homes many people are
living with
i'm afraid we do we are out of time
we're going to have to leave it there
but so david we really appreciate your
thoughts thanks very much
indeed for talking to us today
now still to come for you this morning
big issue sellers
will return to the streets in england
and wales today for the first time since
the third national lockdown we'll speak
to a vendor along with the founder of
the magazine at half past seven
with non-essential shops reopening from
today we'll also talk to the chief
executive of the british retail
consortium that's at 7
40 and at five past eight conservative
mp tobias elwood as ministers
returned to parliament earlier than
expected to pay
tribute to the duke of edinburgh
and so politicians across the uk will
today pay tribute to prince philip who
died on friday at the
grand age of 99 the house of commons the
scottish parliament
and the senate are all being recalled
especially now
while some newspapers are reporting that
prince harry
has also flown into the uk in plenty of
times so he can quarantine
ahead of the duke of edinburgh's funeral
on saturday
our royal correspondent rihanna mills
reports
in westminster as the flags fly at
half-mast
mps will return early and boris johnson
will lead the tributes
for a man who met hundreds of
politicians in his lifetime
and 14 prime ministers but was always
expected
to leave matters of state to the queen
there will be many people
who are members of parliament who will
wish to pay tribute to the work that he
did to recall
visits to their constituencies things
that
um uh perhaps factories that he opened
or companies that he visited or
charities that he visited
as the family prepare for the funeral
next saturday there are reports that
prince harry
is now in the uk the first time he's
been back
since the sussexes decided to step away
and move to america
and did that interview with oprah some
suggesting the duke's death may be an
opportunity
for reconciliation outside church
on sunday prince philip's
daughter-in-law sophie
shared details of his final moments
it was so gentle
prince andrew describing how the queen
is coping
as they all rally around her i feel very
sorry
um and supportive of my mother who's um
feeling it i think probably more than
everybody else
she described his passing as a miracle
and um and she's
um contemplating i think is the way that
i would put it there
she described it as as having left a
huge void
prince edward swapping stories with
staff from the estate
about what a character his father had
been he went carriage driving around
here on a regular basis and
and but he'd go to places that you know
were quite you know all over the place
and uh
so we're just talking about them killed
out of a few ditches here i seem to
remember as well
oh well the early days yesterday just
have a few problems
more recently too the tributes have been
just
fantastic and that's really really
important and we really do appreciate it
and princess anne released this loving
photo of her father
saying you know it's going to happen but
you're never really ready
my father has been my teacher my
supporter
and my critic but mostly it is his
example
of a life well-lived and service freely
given that i most
wanted to emulate it is incredibly rare
to hear members of the royal family
speaking this personally
and i think one of the reasons they are
is because they can't come out and see
for themselves the flowers that people
are bringing
but they do want to acknowledge just how
much it means to them
and also how they've been lifted by
hearing those memories of prince philip
some that they've never even heard
before
the nation has so often turned the queen
in difficult times
now her majesty and her family are
finding comfort
from the public reanon mills sky news
at windsor castle
and of course we will have full coverage
of the funeral
of the duke of edinburgh here on sky
news that's on
saturday our coverage starts at two
o'clock
now david cameron has broken his silence
on the lobbying row which has doged him
in recent weeks
the former prime minister stands accused
of abusing his position by
repeatedly lobbying former colleagues to
help green seal capital
which has since gone bust in a statement
he insisted he complied with the rules
but conceded that communications with
government should be done only
through formal channels to avoid what he
called
misinterpretation when our political
correspondent joe pike
is here benefit of hindsight joe
yeah it's sort of a hint of regret from
mr cameron but let's be clear
he has released this statement more than
three weeks after the story started
and they've been coming out pretty
consistently over the last
three weeks some criticism from both
labour and conservative mps that he's
almost
slipped out the statement on a sunday at
a time after the death of the duke of
edinburgh
where criticism of others of political
foes
is pretty muted and that it isn't a
particularly
a good time to get out that statement it
was no apology
in the statement either and it concerns
mr cameron's relationship of course this
whole story
with a guy called lex green seal a
financial uh
services businessman who he brought into
his own government the center of his own
administration
but also lobbied on behalf of mr green
sill
during the covert pandemic to try and
get access to
cheap loans now the cameron statement
was quite long this is the key paragraph
though he says
there are important lessons to be
learned as a former prime minister
i accept that communications with
government need to be done
through only the most formal of channels
so there can be no
room for misinterpretation let's be
clear he's sort of regretting the fact
that he
texted rishi sunak he contacted two
other junior
treasury ministers and he also before
the cover pandemic had a drink
with matt hancock now the last three
weeks we've had pretty consistently lots
of stories from the sunny times of
natural times about this
it may not be the end even if of this
story even though
mr cameron is potentially trying to draw
a line under it
and this is the view of sir alistair
graham who used to be the chair of the
committee
on standards in public life it's about a
level playing field the private sector
should all have a similar access to
government
and there's no reason why the prime
minister or the
chief executive of the company couldn't
have just written to the treasury
in the same way that any other company
asking
for some uh advice
mr cameron still has not spoken on
camera still has not answered really any
detailed questions on this
i think there will still be uh
journalists
at least from sky news wanting to ask
questions to him
it doesn't know stephen at this point
seemed to be any formal investigation
into
his actions either as prime minister or
after he left office
the treasury select committee decided
not to investigate it but it's possible
that they could
change their mind after most recent
revelations
now let's see what the weather's going
to do for you today morning joe it's all
about the wardrobe choices isn't it
put its way in land a little bit but
also we've just had a flurry of text
messages saying it's snowing in london
and it is indeed there's an area of her
rain sleet and snow
gave about six or seven centimeters of
falling snow over
wales this morning it's traveling its
way south eastwards crossing over us now
and then disappearing off towards the
southeast other than that we've got a
north east southwest divide let's take a
look
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you yes
we've got very cold air over still
uh temperatures back to minus eight for
the third night running last night
but we've also got clearer skies towards
the north and the east and then more in
the way of cloud across
ireland wales the south west central
southern parts of england and it's this
which is carrying that
area of rain sleet and snow and pushing
its way south eastwards
first thing this morning but it will
eventually clear and then the cloud
thins and breaks a little bit in these
southwestern areas
whilst we see clouds bubbling up in
these northeastern places so eventually
we get a bit of a balance going on
and the emphasis pretty much on dry
weather i'm not saying there won't be
any showers in these
southwestern areas because there will
but hopefully they will start to become
more scattered
temperatures 10 or 11 degrees celsius
not too bad 52 degrees fahrenheit
in the southwest under the clearer skies
still single figures so it is a little
on the
chilly side but when you get some
sunshine it will actually feel quite
pleasant if you are out in the sun
and then to end the day a lot of that
cloud starts to disappear clear skies
again tonight means another cold one
temperatures well below freezing so a
widespread frost but the weather's
looking nice again for tomorrow and
fewer showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well let's return now to the death of
prince philip who died on friday at the
age of 99. he spent
decades working as a full-time royal
and only retr was retired in 2017. well
let's
talk to press association photographer
yui mark who
photographed the duke of edinburgh at
his last individual public engagement
in 2017. it's good to see you this
morning how does it feel i mean
i guess you knew at the time but it it
reiterates it even
more now doesn't it that the pictures
you took are now
a piece of history
um good morning um yeah it's it's like
most
of the aim of most photographers or
you know great it's a great to make a
great picture is
is to capture the decisive moment and um
i think on this occasion
um i did capture one of them
and um that was the duke at his last
ever
uh public solo engagement and that was a
different view um my abiding memory
of the occasion was the absolutely
appalling weather
it was um downpour and uh
it was a typical british you know uh
sorry
autumn weather but um the duke was there
uh simple attire in a raincoat bowler
hats
no fuss no airs or races and he just got
on with the job
and it was amazing and quite
inspirational really but
there's something about the tipping of
the hat
isn't there you know as as he walked off
which
which you capture so beautifully in
which you know it
epitomizes someone of his age i guess it
just gets the mood absolutely right
um for sure um there's a it's a very
dignified
um you know um
look and uh it's just there's a lot
spoken of him recently about his uh
stoicism and his um
you know um
no-nonsense approach in a way uh he's
very forthright
but um he gives he's very generous to
his subjects
when he um uh does his engagement so he
gives them
all the time um and you know
he's um he's a very um
old-school man uh gentleman
how hard is it that these sort of events
to capture the sense of occasion
in a picture um
it's a lot of it's down to luck um
where you're positioned and if the
subjects
on this occasion are due um
did something um visual
like uh tipping of the hats or um taking
the salute
or making a funny remark to someone you
just it's just um
you're lucky to if you're in the right
place at the right time
um but you use your instincts
and you try to position yourself as best
you can
to capture the capture in a moment how
useful was it on that particular day
that he was
you know with a with a group of people
that he
very much admired i mean obviously his
connection to the armed forces is
absolutely immense and these are men and
women that he
you know he he respected in return i
mean that
again that's captured beautifully in the
pictures it's nice to
almost see him at ease with these sort
of young
fit people who fight for queen and
country
um yes um well his association dates
back to 1953 so he's got
um such a history with the uh
the royal navy they're all marines and
it was fitting really
that he um uh his last engagement was
to um you know uh take the salute
uh and um you know be with them
in a way um and
like he was appointed captain general
and um
and you know this sort of started his
farewell to them
and it's uh you know it's um it
completed the circle what what seems
interesting in a way as we reflect on on
the life of the duke is that
there is nobody else i would i mean you
you get closer to these people than most
of us
but there doesn't seem to be anybody
else who has that
same character i mean that a great
dignity
but also this tremendous irreverence in
in a sense so he was certainly a unique
character wasn't he
he was he was a one-off um and you know
the uh they say they don't make them
like that anymore they certainly don't
and um
he held a lot of values that a lot of
people
could um you know take
lessons from today really um
you know um i know he said he he was
he's very colorful spoke his mind and
didn't take any nonsense
but he's very fair and very generous and
kind
and he's um you know
he's a he's a very modern man in a way
um
but also very old-fashioned and his
traditions
um obviously he was shaped his life was
shaped by the the royal navy
from a young age and uh he carried those
values with him
um for the rest of his life look
really good to talk to you this morning
i know it must be a bit odd being on the
the other side of the lens for you
really good to see you today thank you
thank you very much now as coronavirus
restrictions
further ease across england and wales
big issue sellers
will be back on the streets today about
1400 vendors are going to resume
selling the magazine for the first time
in 22 weeks
since the start of the third lockdown
they're going to be given ppe
and contactless car payments are going
to be encouraged
to maintain safety standards excuse me
let's talk to the co-founder of big
issue
lord john it's really good to see you
this morning
how important is it for these vendors
that they can now
get back out on the streets
well for the last 23 weeks they've been
uh in uh hibernation really
they really want to get on with it uh
they most of them
really like working with the public the
public actually are the people
who make their lives really work so
what we hope is that everybody goes out
when they see the vendors they buy from
the vendors if they can't then
buy through the website the money still
is split
50 50 with our vendors
and this is a really remarkable
opportunity for us we're working
to get the vendors out to get them
selling uh
and hopefully i think selling the big
issue on the street
is a strange indication of a return
to a kind of normality because so many
people
have a brilliant relationship with with
a vendor of two
in and around the country how difficult
has it been for vendors because i mean
one of one of the
the key points of what you have achieved
over the years
is that these are people who need help
need assistance but they're not
asking for donations are there there's
they are selling
a product and you know that carries a
certain amount of
of respect in that sense so
to be to have that taken away from them
for so long must have been hugely
difficult
yeah i was with a group of vendors on
wednesday when we did a
we did a kind of publicity shop and it
was
electric and the reason for that is
because they have this thirst
to get on with the work they look upon
as work they look upon it as their
opportunity
uh and as you say they're they're
they're working
that you know they're not asking for a
donation they're asking for something
that
uh uh makes sense to us all
so um this is a real high point the
other thing is that what's happened over
the last year
is that our business has changed so that
we've become
closer and closer to the vendors we've
been able to work
much more hand-to-hand you know one to
one with them
and all of them are saying they want to
use this as an
opportunity to improve their lives again
which is exactly what we
the reason we started the big issue 30
years ago
what sort of assistance have they been
given what have you been able to do for
them
during this time when they've not been
able to get out selling
well we've been able to give them money
we've been able to give them
goods we've been able to give them uh
coupons which they can use in the
supermarket we've been able to talk with
them
and kind of help them in a kind of
psychological way
and that is really a very strange thing
because we started the big issue to give
people a hand
up not a handout and over the last year
what we've had to do is we've had to
keep supporting them and supporting them
now is the chance hopefully if this is
the last lockdown
hopefully this is a chance for them to
get back to where they want to be
which is determining their own lives
determining
what they can do how much money they
make how much effort they they can put
in
what effort they need to get off the
streets to move on
and to rebuild their lives
well the lockdown easing takes another
step today and it includes the reopening
of
non-essential shops i for one i'm
desperate for some new towels
don't ask why it's got to be done today
now the chief executive of the british
retail consortium
helen dickinson joins me now look helen
really good to see you this morning this
is clearly a very big day and a big step
what have shops had to do to prepare for
this moment
uh well it is it's a big day isn't it
for for the country and it's a big day
for all of those businesses
um across uh certainly england and wales
uh reopening their doors today so i'm
sure you're gonna be able to find some
towels somewhere but
what they've been doing is many of those
businesses have had people on furlough
so bringing those people back
making sure that they're um they're
happy and ready for work
making sure the stores are prepared that
they're clean and safe
and that they've got all the stock that
they want and need in the right place
in order to be able to welcome people
back so they've
they are very excited i know that from
talking to lots of them over the last
few weeks they are desperate to welcome
their customers back
um and it is a big day the focus there
on
on on safety and and um excitement
really
yeah the safety is is clearly the the
key issue i mean obviously a lot of them
were operating in covered safe ways
before
the the latest shutdown for them so has
it been difficult to sort of bring those
procedures
back in play
uh no no actually i think because
they've
you know been through the process before
often on
on various occasions because if if we
all remember back
to last year seems like a lifetime ago
but as well as the national lockdowns we
had the various tier systems across
different parts of
of the country um and so i think they
that you know they would have been ready
last week the week before and are just
keen
and enthusiastic about welcoming people
back so
i think it's much more about what we
will see
in terms of us all as as customers and
our behaviors
and ensuring that we've got the
confidence to come back and also
that we as members of the public have a
a part to play
in you know following the the the
signage the
um the guidance that we get given cueing
if we need to um weigh marking around
the stores and all
of the safety procedures that are there
in place so we've got a role too
yeah um look how many businesses
it or you know what what sort of level
of proportion of businesses are looking
at today as
as either sort of do or die if you like
how many businesses
really need this to work pretty quickly
in order to stay afloat
well what we've seen over the course of
the three lockdowns is about
30 billion pounds of lost sales
through stores that that didn't happen
because those stores were closed um and
so
there will be hundreds thousands of
businesses
up and down the country where it's
really important
um what does happen over the coming
days and weeks certainly i think the
feeling is that there will be a a bit of
pent-up demand
out there and that people will come back
not only
because they they need something but
also because
you know they want to play a part in
their local community
and because um it you know there is a
an enjoyment for lots of people in um
in going shopping and therefore having
everything available to us all again um
over the coming days and weeks
is is going to be you know a real major
part in terms of
our feeling that we're getting some of
our you know so-called
normal life back so um i hope that
that that everybody will support their
local businesses
and um those businesses can play their
part in the recovery and that we don't
lose too many more of them
i just wonder what sort of difference
you're expecting between i mean someone
like a
a shopping center you would expect to be
you know comparatively busy and at least
people can move from one shop to another
there's going to be a difference isn't
there to be between that and the turnout
we're likely to see on
on your average high street
well one of the characteristics that
certainly we
saw um during the course of
last year when all of retail was open
is the effect of working from home for
lots of people
so big cities big urban centers
that's actually where the the footfall
has been hit
hardest because often that footfall was
driven
by people who were going to and from
work or going out in their lunch time uh
or by by tourists as well and we have um
seen uh not so many of the the latter
and certainly everybody's working
patterns whether they've been going into
a workplace or
for the half or so of the population
that's been working from home
have been very different so so i think
local
high streets and towns will be busier
perhaps than big urban centres
shopping centers i think we will we will
see
um an uptick on what we've seen before
but i think it will it will kind of
depend
on how confident people feel to to get
back out there and hopefully
you know given all the investment in in
safety that those businesses have made i
hope
i hope that everybody will are you quite
confident that people will be sort of
happy to switch away from online which
of course we've been
almost full forced to use over the last
12 months quite a lot
well i think online is a major part of
of retail it was a growing part of
retailing
in advance of march 2020 and what we've
seen on the back of the
pandemic is is that growth has really
accelerated
so i think what pretty much
every business that i talk to expects to
see
in the future is a much closer
connection if you like between
physical retailing and digital retailing
um such that for us as shoppers they're
much more sort of seamlessly connected
i mean we already think about things
like click and collect
we will certainly i think see much more
of that
and you know how those businesses
use social media and connection with
their customers
much more in the future so i think it's
it's much more about how they work
together with each other online offline
physical
and digital rather than seeing them
seeing them as in competition
yeah yeah look helen really good to talk
to you i have to say if you want towels
you've got to go and feel them first
haven't you
it's just the way with towels i'm going
to enjoy my shop today
good to see you hope you get some good
tales thanks oh i will
okay let's see what the weather's going
to do for you today here's joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning well it looks as though
quite a few people will be out and about
today
uh so the weather really we've got to
divide north and in the eastern parts
very cold start today plenty of sunshine
to come
but it won't be that warm whereas where
it's more cloudy down towards the
southwest a few outbreaks of showery
rain
but these should die out during the day
you